Can you hear me? How you doing, man? You
uh disagree? Uh Jesus is God. Changed my
mind. Yeah, I I disagree. I'm Muslim by
first. Okay. Um and and the reason and
the reason that I say Jesus Jesus is not
God because nobody knows how Jesus looks
like. For example, let me just let me
give an example. Let me give an example.
Wait, you're saying Jesus is not God
because no one knows what Jesus looks
like? You No. No. Yes. No. Let Let me
explain. Let me explain. Let's let's
just talk about Jesus uh the persona
himself, right? If you look up look up
Google and you type in Jesus or you go
to the Vatican or you go to Ethiopia,
they all have like pictures of Jesus how
he looks like. So now my point of view
is like if you're saying like Jesus is
God, okay, then you have like this type
of image that is contributed to it
because you're trying to what does that
what does that got to do with that? What
does that have to do with Jesus himself?
So what it has to do with Jesus is what
it has to do with Jesus is like what if
you found out that totally doesn't look
like just to be clear if I drew pictures
of Allah does that mean that that Allah
is not God because I have pictures of
him? No. Because nobody knows how God
looks like, right? So he doesn't look
like he's created. So does So if I'll
ask it again cuz I don't know if you
hear yourself. You said that Jesus you
said Jesus can't be God because people
drew pictures of him and we don't and we
don't know what he looks like. So if I
drew pictures of Allah even though I
don't know what he looks like, but I
drew pictures and I said that this is
Allah, does that mean that Allah is not
God anymore? No. Because God is not just
like his creation. Okay. So, so if I, so
people create, so people making painting
pictures of what they depict as Jesus
has nothing to do with Jesus and him
being God, right? No, Jesus is not God.
All right. Tell me why Jesus Christ. So
tell me why Jesus is not God. Because
first because first of all, like I like
I said, people have this like this image
when you just look at Jesus. Brother,
tell me why Jesus is not God. Don't tell
me about pictures. Tell me why Jesus is
not God. Because we again and this will
be the last time. I'm not like I'm not
going to entertain this anymore. If I
drew pictures of Allah, you wouldn't say
that Allah is not God anymore cuz I drew
pictures of him. This is stupid. So give
me something real that shows that Jesus
is not God. Give me give me a real
argument. Okay. So who is who is then
Jesus father then? If Jesus is God, who
is his father? The heavenly father.
Because he came he No, no, no. You you
said no no no. I just I just gave you
the answer to your question. The
heavenly father is Jesus's father. So
what's what's what now? It is it's more
confusing now because Jesus came out out
of No, Jesus came out of a of out of a
virgin, right? Jesus says that he came
down from heaven. How did he how did he
come down from heaven? Jesus was born
out of a virgin, right? But he says that
he came down from heaven before he was
born of a virgin. So, how could he come
down from heaven? Wait, Jesus came out
of a out of a virgin. I'll say I I'll
say it again slowly. I'll say it again
slowly. Okay. Jesus says I'm going to
say it slowly again. Okay. Jesus says,
okay, I came down from heaven. So before
he was born of a virgin, before he took
on a human nature and was born of a
virgin, he came down from heaven. How
did Jesus come down from heaven if he's
not God? So God in that sense you're
trying to tell me that God has needs
needs needs to come on earth through a
through a bi biological process my
brother to do what I I don't feel like
this is I don't I don't feel this is
fair it's more confusing for you huh
yeah yeah yeah you're confusing me get
off my stage thank you ma'am
I just felt three brain cells pop please
come back sweetheart can you bring me
some tea some brain cell tea you got
them. Yeah, I just lost three of them.
That's painful. Jeez. Imagine going
through that every day. Like having
none. That has to hurt living like that,
right? Our friend servant is here.
Servant of the most merciful. What's
going on every
What you got for me today? What's What's
happening? Nothing much, man. Nothing
much. Trying to be like you with
interesting titles, man. Good. Good. Uh
I've had some discussions, you know, and
I want to It's a more of a clarification
and it depends on your answer. I can
maybe make an argument. Okay. If you
answer correctly, I think I I won't
answer. Who Who gives authority to
Jesus? When Jesus set aside his divine
privileges and took on flesh and was
exalted, it was the father who exalted
Jesus and gave him authority. So, he
gives him the authority to forgive sins.
That's what you're saying. Oh, no.
That's it doesn't say that he has that
innately within himself. Oh, so he was
never given authority to forgive sins.
He just already had it. So, when you say
authority, so it's a category of
authority. It's a it's so it's not about
forgiving sins. What is it about then?
What's this authority? So when you see
when Jesus is um resurrected and he's
getting ready to ascend and he's
glorified, he's uh this authority that
he has this glory or this position that
he has. He's seated at the right hand of
the father. And so that's the type of
authority that he is given when he has
sins, when he's glorified. What about
when he's has on the flesh? Uh uh isn't
that true that Jesus also forgives sin
and that's that's a that's the father
gives him that authority to forgive sins
and you're saying it's not the case
maybe Christians I misunderstand
Christians yeah you I it seems like you
misunderstand that so Jesus innately has
the the ability to you know forgive sins
so that's why he's able to do it cuz
he's the son of man um now the authority
that he's given you know uh at his at
his glorification is his exaltation and
being exalted above all of creation,
sitting at the right hand of the father,
above the angels, above men, above every
principality, everything. Okay. Um, and
what about performing miracles? Was it
something that Jesus himself is doing or
is the father doing himself? Well, it's
it's it's not either or, it's all of it.
you have um the father um working
through the son by the spirit that is
indwelling in Jesus um and he's
performing these miracles. So it's it's
all of them you know are are are taking
part in Jesus performing these miracles.
Okay. So so so but but who's who's
committing who's doing the act? Who is
the Jesus is doing the act? Okay. So in
in a race in Lazarus Jesus says I thank
you oh father you have heard me you
always hear me. What does it mean? I can
understand that this is a request that
he's asking for him asking for him to
help him raise Lazarus from that. Well,
he doesn't say that. He doesn't say that
he's asking him. He doesn't say that. It
looks like that for me. Yeah. Yeah. So,
so what we see is we see Jesus
addressing the father because and and he
literally says why he's doing it. He
says so that they may see and know that
you have sent me and that you always
hear me. Right? And so what he's doing
is is he is displaying putting on
display the intimate relationship that
he has with the father. So it's not to
his benefit but it's to the benefit of
the audience to see that he truly is
from the father and is the son in whom
he said like he said he was he said
himself right before this he says I am
the resurrection and the life. So yeah.
Yeah, I can I can understand what you're
saying. If I say yes, he's doing it only
to show people uh uh show something to
people. But but what you're saying
implies he was pretending even though
even though he's doing it to show them
that he's he has that communication with
that father that you should also have
that communication with God. But it
seems that he going to be pretending or
you hear me. So is he pretending or hear
me about what? Why is he was he just
saying Jesus is thanking him? Why is he
just thanking him? Is he pretending to
thank him? That's what I'm asking. No,
everything that's happening is genuine,
but everything is everything that's
happening is not for his benefit. It's
for the audience. I think I lost him for
a second. You there, servant? Hello,
servant. Is you there? All right, I lost
him.